[Music]
welcome back to nirach stars I'm Phil
Molina and this is robe theory it's a
show where we dive into all kinds of
nerdy things that are happening in the
Nerdist sphere and we bring nerds here
to theorize it and get weird about it
and we have some right here
we got Eric Foss our own boy hometown
hero hi that's me yeah and then from
MTV's are you the one are you the one we
have Danny say your own lesson Danny
forecast forecast right and then
Angelica Trey from twitch reminder that
you can listen to rogue theory as a
podcast all our stuff that's on podcast
comes out earlier so if you can't wait
because you're really into this then
just get on the podcast version or if
you drive places and need things to hear
guys on this episode we have things
about we're gonna hit spider-man again
we are also going to talk about some
Star Trek news and we'll do our road
questions at the end but to start things
out we're actually gonna hit up I
believe we're all done now with
strangers day real quick and I get a
stranger things too theme song oh I
thought we're all riffing we all took a
different synth sound
strange great what you guys think of the
ending specifically of a strange things
how did it leave you feeling this I love
that stranger things ends every season
with a big cliffhanger to force us to
wonder about what's coming next season
and for me like you know spoiler warning
for people haven't seen all eight
episodes again but like seeing the dimma
Gorgon show up again isn't the big
question to me it's who is the American
in the other cell to me it's gotta be
popper
everyone thinks it's hopper but I feel
like it could probably be I don't know
maybe someone like season two yeah
Serena Williams she's a famous American
known abroad yeah she's got a killer
overhand serve there's like a Russian
sleeper agent
experienced internationally and yeah
she's world world renowned and no one
would question it I know here's my hot
take on this guys so I think with with
stranger things every season is dealing
with all these like 80s references and
they probably of a checklist of ones
that they haven't done yet and my
thinking is if this is the fourth and
final season because these kids are
getting old how much more can you get
out of them
what if we time jump to the end of the
end of the decade and we have something
like flight of the navigators thing
which has not been done yet it's one of
the people I feel like there's been a
hint of flight of the navigator actually
where kid goes missing but oh but that's
interesting
well that and then also just the the way
that they build their stuff or something
there's like like aesthetic choices
other than navigator yeah but but also
if you haven't seen part of the
navigator what else from the 80s can
they still mind I think they could just
keep ripping off of neverending story
honestly yeah I really want to see Mike
gets super into Oingo Boingo okay yeah
my pitch I even though they referenced
it a little bit in season one I want to
see I mean this is just me but I'm into
like poltergeist and I'm into me et has
a lot of the same vibe but poltergeist
is like a scarier version of et where
it's
thing that strange things has always had
is a little bit of like the the magic
that like hooks you even as a child but
then the thing that gives you like
nightmares and you're not allowed to
watch ET anymore I have I want them to
have that vibe with but and this
pacifically that's a very personal and
then yeah for six months and then you go
to a different school that it's called a
hospital and then but a poltergeist
alter Geist has a it's not the best
sequel but but they have one thing that
could play in with the fact that the
buyers family just moved away and
poltergeist it follows them mm-hmm so it
should you know Carolyn goes and I
believe there stays like some hotel or
something and so the guys goes and finds
her there so it is interesting if maybe
something can leave Hawkins it's not
tied to a location but rather it's tied
to a person but that person needs me ask
a question though because I feel like
they did put into this season that the
the location is very important Alexey
Smirnoff talks about how like they had
the key and that was one part of the
equation and they needed to take it to a
location but obviously later on they
were in some Russian prison camp at the
end and had some potentially they have a
number of these gates scattered around
the world it seems like throughout the
season the mind flayers grudge against
eleven is personal so well he's gonna
find her wherever she just Roger's it a
this is the one person who can stop me
when I've seen that eleven is the one
that left also I'll just throw out there
that yes it's like the Hellmouth kind of
like it's underneath but also they
treated this season a lot like infection
and that's the idea right of patient
zero going like can take something and
bring it do you guys know that rabies is
not a thing in Europe what it's not
popular but what if the mine flare is
actually in love with eleven
was building like boom you and Juliet
the entire season we're building this
for you and then it just wanted a little
smooch arou at the end we melt all your
friends I'm gonna take credit for all of
this right now as being my theory for
what's gonna happen next season let's
hear some other theories of places that
can go maybe spun off of a movie you
can't go to flight of the navigator sir
okay okay my idea for flying a navigator
is like seeing where these characters as
the same age that they are maybe we've
recast a lot of the characters so kind
of like the snap yeah a character goes
missing they're still young but due to
the different physics of the upside down
maybe they come back and they're all
adults and they have to deal with the
real buyers who used to be the the
immature one now he's super immature and
he's still a kid you're specifically
saying we want to recast will buyers
cast everybody else I will say that some
people do want to recast well buyers I'm
just saying it was really really bizarre
towards the end of the new season to see
will was actually taller than his mother
you know it was weird the camera angle
he was taller than her but also in his
shot he looked like he was like a giant
weird hot take I really wanted will to
be gay okay maybe there's that question
right Sam I thought you don't like girls
yeah you are a gay character will you're
gay you're gay you're gay that line in a
gay club and he's just like a little
awkward he's like oh yeah what's
interesting actually real quick on that
note I remember Lee into the fact that
they made that character a lesbian yeah
because that to me is the one thing so I
thought they did an amazing job
recreating the 80s specifically in the
mall it was just like a wave of
nostalgia from that time but the one
thing that 80s pop culture doesn't have
is gay culture being part of it a lot
there's a lot of fear of gay culture
specifically in the 80s worse than even
before the 80s it was yeah I mean it is
related to the AIDS epidemic but that
also made it
like a threat instead so now to go back
and it's almost revisionist history but
to be able to be like yet they were
still gay people in 80's probably the
same exact number there are now so no
I'm super into that and I'm also into
the idea of will being gay just it feels
like like math wise yeah with a group
that size statistically one of them 75%
yes yeah I remember what that see that
scene two with Robin talking to Steve
Harrington and they were going through
it like after the drug trip right I was
like oh my god it's gonna be a love
scene I hate this already and then have
to be puked they're gonna make it Robin
dropped that bomb and I was like yes and
Steve handled it so well and it felt so
good when when Robin like leaned into
her arms and was like oh man I hate that
this is happening I was like oh she got
boyfriend what's going on he has a crush
on Tammy yeah I mean who doesn't have a
crush what is great about that she sings
poorly yeah
is that it takes it away from Steve like
allowing her to be
I love interest to him where he's like
it's like the holsters it's impossible I
could never like her and then like her
Ark is that Steve's willing to like her
by the end that's what it would have
been if it was just as simple as that so
I like that real quick on the your pitch
for the flight of the navigator hydrogen
avail a time job it's also what I love
about it when you read it and also even
the TV movie version of it and what its
sequel is gonna be with Bill Hader and
Stephen King's it just goes yeah oh yeah
I know I'm just being real big
I love that that is not the thing which
was a big part of this it was but the
idea of them coming back as adults and
having to like reseal it that's all one
of the few ways that I think you can get
away with once again it's open and they
got to deal with it again but what if
it's open thirty years later or
something and yeah maybe so well or
something like that is making me think
about Mad Men which is definitely a less
nerdy show but they always talked about
especially towards the end of their
series like this is a show that exists
in the 60s right and we don't want to go
into the 70s it just wouldn't work for
us and this is a show that exists in the
80s but I kind of want to see them do
like a little bit of a Boogie Nights
thing you know like I don't know if
y'all have seen Boogie Nights with this
thing where it's like they had the New
Year's for like going from the 70s into
the eighties and I guess Boogie Nights
had a very different opinion of babies
than like tougher brothers did but like
I will has Monster a lot more blow a lot
more porn and a lot more suicide yeah
cool for them to be like hey remember
how great the 80s were ready for the
shitstorm that was the 90s because this
is what we think of back in garbage yeah
or two timelines right and it's a little
lost style we get we get forward and
flashback and maybe even a little bit of
the constant from loss but also
slaughterhouse-five unstuck in time you
linked yeah and you're actually having
to do things at the same time in both
timelines yeah in order to solve it so
time in general is something a
stranger's things hasn't really played
and pretty much every period show does
some version of this I mean the
Americans had a time jump of a couple
years and at the final season took place
during the start negotiations at the end
of the decade whereas most of it was set
in 1983 1984 so this isn't unprecedented
it's just jump to the interesting points
of the decade and the end of the 80s was
very interesting with the collapse of
the Soviet Union what if something
happens where the Soviet Union security
collapse is just like there is all these
rumors that the Soviets lost their nukes
so there's missing rogue nukes around
there rogue theory what if there's a
rogue demagogue in that that a Soviet
Union because of its collapse because of
events like Chernobyl have allowed these
things to be released into the world the
thing you're talking about to this this
demagogue in that's over there
Russia did we talk about this yet the
idea that that might not be in present
time right that could be in the past
that could be before all this is set or
his way out or wouldn't the scene say
ten years later or something like that
yeah you win if Jim hopper were in that
cell as the American he'd just be an old
man and this is actually really Jim
hopper could be any other American an
old man is Jim it could be one of the
precursors to 11 because we know she met
eight and season two and there are all
these other experiments before she it
was there was a 15-minute recap of last
season and there's not one shot other
she just comes back looking like was it
Rufus from Bill and Ted yeah so I'm
wondering they might be like you know
what let's just leave it at 11 which is
also why I don't think they would recast
right all right but talking about
talking about Russia talking about the
scene at the end the cliffhanger
I mean before we consider who the
American is we have to talk about like
if the American is hopper house hopper
alive could hopper be alive
what's the same way 11 ended up being
alive you get sucked into the or you
show up through another one of those
gate portals that they already have
right and there's I also feel like I'd
have to rewatch in a slow mode like I do
everything else but I feel like there's
a chance that the you know what was
creating that barrier for him of why he
couldn't cross through there was like
that spinning blue fan I feel like the
guys that we did see melt were on the
other side of it as possible right that
protected him and I guess I mean come on
like we don't see hopper die we don't
see a body either right we don't see a
body we see these other folks get
vaporized we see sort of like their
ashes and remains we don't get a single
shot that even hints at that for how it
would be it would be the kind of thing
where he like makes like last second eye
contact with a woman owner writer
so dramatic right I mean that woman is
ruined already is what we've all learned
from the editing of that sequence was
illiterate yeah like she a Winona Ryder
closes her eyes looks away from the
blinding light that was all the choice
so that she didn't look at the bank it
seems like it was a big jump to go from
the edge of the platform
into the rift into the gate here's the
question is the upside down better than
death because I was late on sounds
really really scary scary hell please
it's just a she life is no there's a
monsters over there over here who knows
what though one giant monster that just
keeps sticking up up his nose the whole
time that's where I'm headed I don't
know about you guys that's what I'm
thinking he's gonna be even more
traumatized than your ideas oh yeah I'm
gonna scope this way down to just asking
what do you guys think is gonna happen
with that dummy Corrigan over in Russia
so I have a question about physics in
this world and it sounds like not an
answer gotta get towards an answer but
like in the first series wasn't the
demagogue ins sort of a planeswalker
like it could go between the upside down
and no reality back and forth from it
but it would just sort of open gates
wherever it wanted to crawl out go back
in and like album
yeah it is that because there was
already a gate open a nearby date there
was sort of like a permeable surface or
did you just have that ability it was
this status of their dimension was the
lines are being blurred yeah like right
in every way consider the shape of a
funnel at the bottom of the funnel is
the actual gate but as it all swoops
down into and if you're Hawkins you're
closer to the bottom hole of the funnel
you poor poor funnel can we get a straw
so you're the flea so maybe because of
close proximity with it within a radius
yeah you can been through bedroom walls
okay yeah the Russians just have to be
really careful about opening that rift
otherwise their demo Gorgons gonna go
bye-bye do you think the demagoguing
will have caused Chernobyl in season
four although I watch it in the back of
every scene there's actually a little
demo Gordon terrible skin eric has a pet
peeve about depicting time travel or
space travel through wormholes by using
a folded piece of paper and sticking a
pencil through yeah how do you feel
about this example of the the dimensions
that Alexi was giving with straw yeah at
least he didn't fold it that's always a
silly way to do it was it it was into a
it wasn't into just a piece of paper
though it was into and then used the
wrapper of the burger just use new I
always love like new creative solutions
to do it like let's let's see like or
maybe have a scene that's just meta
about like doesn't no one has a straw I
think the fun thing was how obviously
incapable that straw was of penetrating
anything because like that was one of
those Slurpee straws and they've got
that fun little scooper down on the
bottom and it's just so hard to sticks
to this and it happens to a lot of guys
they taste like
read that I love the taste director the
flavor chemical responsible for cherry
flavor is the same as for almond flavor
but when it's in lower concentrations
it's almond when it's in higher
concentrations it's cherry is it blood
it's blood yeah
what is the demo Gorgon and rush I gonna
do okay I think we'll find out that the
demagogue in can appear in different
points around the world causing
disasters that we but he was in a cage
bars right but we all saw that is gonna
be like a war hound right and they're
gonna use to find term just literally
like I don't know they're gonna use it
as like a weapon yeah sure really cool
think about on think about Hunger Games
with those like specialties I think
about but like maybe they're gonna like
try to do some genetic experiment
tracker jackers yeah tracker jacker
aliens like doing aliens demo Corgan's
is the name yeah well you know they were
demo dogs and they were not full posit
okay and we'll do it right after we just
say thank you to the people that pay for
the show robe theories brought to you by
some very friendly sponsors it's
summertime so you got to get that summer
haircut your summer outfit and best of
all you gotta get your summer theme to
underwear me undies has the coolest
summer designs watermelons fireworks
pool floaties plan to wears livin it up
right now seriously I mean it I got a
bunch of this underwear recently and it
is my current favorite underwear not
just because it looks pretty good on but
also just the softest freakin underwear
I've ever had I guess that's because
they're scientists at me undies created
micro modal's some sort of high-tech
supersoft fabric it is three times
softer than cotton whatever it is it
made these scientists my favorite of all
the underwear scientists that I know me
Indies have the great offer for our
listeners for any first-time purchasers
when you purchase any me Andes product
you get 15% off and free shipping get
15% off a pair of the most comfortable
undies you will ever put on also they do
pajama pants which I am literally
wearing right now to get your 15% off
you
first pair free shipping and a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee
go to me and these comms flash rockstars
that's me on DS comm slash rockstars
okay it's 1:00 a.m. and you're halfway
through the new season of stranger
things and those waffle cravings just
kicked in
but you don't gotta leave your couch coz
you can just post mate it post mate is
your year-round personal food delivery
grocery delivery whatever kind of
delivery service you need there it
anything you're craving post mates can
deliver they're the largest on-demand
network in the US and they offer
delivery from pretty much every
restaurant grocery store anything else
you could possibly want or need 24 hours
a day 365 days a year
post mates will bring it to you within
the hour no more trips to the store you
don't even need to know where the store
is post mates will deliver anything to
you including this Pad Thai which I am
literally eating right now seriously
download the free app for iOS or Android
browser restaurants and businesses and
track your delivery in real time for a
limited time post mate is giving our
listeners $100 of free delivery credit
for your first 7 days so to start your
free deliveries download the app and use
code rockstars
that's code rockstars for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
when you download the post-match app
anything you need anytime you need it
post mate it download post mates and
save with code rockstars cool we're back
and yes I'm wearing me undies right now
also Angelica has a theory about this
past season a stranger thing I do and
maybe we can tie it into the next one
but if we all remember and whenever the
the mind flayer took over like possessed
somebody essentially they started eating
chemicals and fertilizer right yeah my
theory was that the mind flare was going
to go to the funfair
and like blow it up primarily with
nitrogen nitrogen is also using a lot of
explosives and I'm sure assorted
chemicals as well yeah did you want to
finish the Hobby process which is used
to ground nitrogen was originally
invented to make explosives but then was
later used to spark agriculture with
fertilizer don't know why I know that
maybe its plans got foiled and I was
like alright I just got to go after it
right now but I think maybe this could
tie in if say the Russians opened up
another rift and then it came back out
it's almost like it's like directly a
war why they were consuming was it to
dematerialize their body make them
easier into goop that's that is one
theory that I've heard but my theory is
way cooler I'm just so glad speaking of
explosions the people didn't blow up the
way the rats did I mean they basically
they melted which was a lot more
palatable for me man it was but it was
honestly the creature design even though
it was so disgusting I think that's a
testament to how original it was that we
haven't seen that of just like yeah what
if reformed people bones teeth it's
literally I mean not to be morose aren't
the best literally like what a tumor is
it's like a mismatch of just like
genetic code just building random thing
and that's kind of what these people be
left over like actual Anatomy like the
rat tail being dragged along yeah but
like the monster was rad like when I
first saw the monster it's like oh cool
so I'm sort of new melty monster and
then like the end of episode 3 I think
where it's like oh that's the shape of
the mind flayer yeah but like that was a
corporeal form yeah guys spider-man's by
far from okay I couldn't get through
without laughing it's a funny movie
no I it we really talked about a lot
last week but we talked a lot about
things going on in it and it's okay if
you want to share a little bit about
that but Eric and I were talking about
earlier about where we think it's going
not just with spider-man 3 but also just
in general into phase four so I just
want to hear some rogue theories about
what you think the next spider-man
movies gonna be about what's been set up
are we gonna go sinister six movie you
guys ready for my bit I've got a pretty
big bit that I've been pumping up with
these guys okay I don't know if I'm
ready for this yeah
so let's freeze right there about
another so the first movie spider-man
homecoming mm-hmm second movie
spider-man far from home I'm looking for
a trilogy where all three titles have
home in them third movie spider-man Lucy
I'm home it's all black and white not
home alone oh [ __ ] that's so much better
spider-man can't go home again
spider-man homeless who's Lucy in this
scenario Lucille Ball oh it's still the
bomb
but like they just redo I Love Lucy with
Tom Holland as Desi Arnaz also was that
your does your nose can we have Lucy the
new AI interface standing for couples oh
we're doing oh yeah we know at the end
of spider-man far from home the
post-credits scene jay jonah jameson is
back played by JK the writers have said
that they want JK Simmons to come back
in the third one but we're still waiting
to see how well this does cuz you were
telling me beforehand that apparently
Marvel and Sony have this deal to where
if these spider-man movies do not make
more than a billion dollars or something
this this movie specifically if it does
not make more than a billion dollars the
deal is negated and all the rights go
back to Sony right so I think they can't
start writing it because they don't know
what other MCU things they might not
have access to but I think one thing
they do always have access to is a
sinister six and that is a still a Sony
property all the spider-man villains are
owned by Sony and
if anything Marvel has to ask for rights
and has to come up with a negotiate a
deal to nords use those in these movies
so I think now's the time to finally
have the sinister six have some kind of
role and the fact that you set up JK
Simmons as J jonah Jameson's to come
back and turning spider-man into a
public menace Peter Parker and a public
menace I think we don't know everything
that happened in the first act it's
movie apparently spider-man had all
these deleted scenes where he was
beating up the Manfredi mafia
organization Silvio Manfredi is
Silvermane and there's we also have
Adrian Toomes we have scorpion in this
universe there's even a setup possibly
with like flash Thompson's mom has some
kind of interesting thing going on with
her
could she be established as a Norman or
Norma Osborn figure yeah there's all
kinds of villains that are set up in
this world that they could bring
together have six of them be the
sinister six in this version of the
spider-man movies my only reason why I
mean I'm very excited to see that movie
in the same way that I was very excited
to see the Avengers but ten years after
Ironman came out and not you know two
years after it came out yeah I I don't
want them to setup that many more
villains in one movie so my pitch I just
I really do like the idea of Kraven
being the film they've talked about how
it's gonna be some someone we haven't
seen before but also if you if you go
back to the the really old-school comics
the villains they kind of like later on
they kind of became better threats for
instance Doc Ock is like kind of a
decent threat but but not amazing not
the way that now he's kind of maybe the
most iconic even beyond Green Goblin but
a Green Goblin also is not like that big
a threat at the beginning but Kraven
treated he he plays the idea of the most
dangerous game which the idea of hunting
man and he literally just like just
trying to murder Peter Parker even like
the original classic comics I can treat
him like prey and he was really
effective in this like a creepy way that
like isn't just about explosions
whatever right it's like you have like a
sniper on you at all times it probably
know that that to me is like a very
different type when he was saying we're
gonna do something we haven't done in
spider-man before I thought maybe that
super dark oh yeah I mean I have a
thought of just that like
Mysterio at least in the illusion he was
creating was a big villain like that was
a big villain like I think spider-man
has to go bigger you know like with with
like a series or with like a set of
movies like I think you have to continue
to increase the stakes like he's he's
your friendly neighborhood spider-man
and now he's global like I think we need
to see spider-man in space and I think
that we might need to see it like maybe
an on spider-man villain in the next one
like maybe something crossing him over
and linking him deeper into the MCU well
I mean he'd they definitely have been
trying to do that throughout all these
other movies in Congress doubt that well
what I'll give you on that is that that
to me does to live up to this idea that
spider-man is basically an Avenger now
he's you know always one of the most
senior ones considering they lost a lot
of the senior ones yeah but I like the
one they stay with your friendly
neighborhood spider-man to me I love
raising the stakes rather than you know
this way more like in here like these
things that hit him that much harder
which is why I also I talked about one
more day the comic storyline where Aunt
May dies I mean like like things
happening within that we also still
haven't met Gwen Stacy right yeah yeah
so like there's a lot of like personal
hits that he can take so imagine yeah
there's an assassin I mean that's
borrowing that's mixing two different
storylines if I get Kraven but yeah some
sort of assassin story and it's killing
that especially post his identity being
revealed now we know who is ant is you
know we know who his classmates are we
know his friends are and they just
popping them off well everyone's in
trouble like that's a pretty terrifying
villain to me even though it's it's very
street-level spider-man to go in a
really dark Dragon Con so dark well okay
so just going off with a neighborhood
thing because with the space theory here
they straight-up alluded to that in far
from home right
they mentioned I think Nick Fury
mentioned yeah he was like but I never
had spider-man that was my best
impression yeah very dusty or nose thank
you thank you but I love that theory
Eric but what if what if we have
Mysterio come back but it's
when else right because he's all the
gear you know Tobey Maguire as Mysterio
any poor imitation of Jake Gyllenhaal
he's like brother didn't they do a movie
called brothers where they brother yeah
there you go
so we're just mixing oh no what's darker
than venom as well like that is
something we know Sony if Sony does
fully retain the rights to spider-man I
don't think this movie's gonna clear a
billion dollars easy but I know Sony's
eager to get another venom movie and the
works and their I don't know if you can
see an exact crossover with Tom Hardy's
take on venom and Tom Hollands version
is I don't want that to be the version
because that's the best way to put
that's what Civil War has going for
right what the characters are you both
under you understand both their
motivations and put them in a conflict
with each other yeah you know like
Venom's dark but I feel like something
that was cool about far from home is
that like Mysterio at least in my mind
is kind of a tacky villain lair of a
know like fishbowl yeah but they made
him horrifying like I may not be the
biggest nerd in the room and my like
first introduction to Mysterio was Kevin
Smith the standing that was my first
introduction to Mysteria was in the
spider-man 2 video game for the Gamecube
yeah and he was just like an after boss
sort of and it was like what is this
goofy [ __ ] what is going on so but like
he was horrifying in this movie yes so
you need to read old man Logan okay oh
yeah yeah it's also just like a really
good story to read well and I remember
in the animated series Mysterio is kind
of one of the goofier one see I had that
feeling too but yeah after seeing some
crappy talking about this last week the
MCU does that so well where they're like
wait these are your powers a good guy or
bad guy
then the logical conclusion of that is
like much scarier than you would think
something like if you can actually
create these illusions you know you
could do anything really it sounds like
our votes are you want sinister so yeah
I'm dying for some I'm into just a real
dark place where like Peters friends are
murdered and then you go in for space I
I'll stick with my first one which was
Lucy I'm home
oh damn I like don't she's not alive
anymore right
Lucille dogok exactly okay I like it
very big budget they don't even have
like they'd have to reference the poor
quality film that they shot of Lucille
Ball
sure alright guys so in energy we'll
just say it's probably given its gonna
make it past the 1 billion on its way on
and on I believe the last eight Marvel
films have cleared a billion dollars so
I'm not super worried even though it's
only at six hundred million and I be
terrible yeah hey I want to talk about
another nerd property we don't actually
get to this one very often on this
channel but it's Star Trek specifically
I mean probably in my opinion how take
but not really that the best Captain
Picard so you guys that's Captain so you
guys know that he has his own show
coming out they just dropped this sick
poster if you listening to the podcast
it's an old man and a dog next to each
other but imagine it's real cool Wow
look at oh yeah so my question for you
guys well one I mean if you have
thoughts on Picard specifically and what
you're looking for from this this series
and great I'd love to hear them I'm a
big card fan but if you're not what
other character do we need to go back to
like 30 years ago and bring back on
their own spin-off series there goes I
mean I'm just hoping the card will be
similar but I think he's quoted
to have said that Picard's gonna be
different and it's what 20 years later
how much later real-life know the show
is set the bail is set 20 years I think
after TNG ends the next generation and
Picard is the best captain just getting
that out there but I'm not sure maybe
they'll have the cue in there fingers
crossed I kind of hope personally
honestly that they like like just start
kind of a bunch of new characters and
villains because they if they stay well
more that like what next generation
doesn't have going for it to me is like
the the villains are I don't know
they're like a little like like cheesy
honestly TV villa yeah I like I really
like his Borg storyline person even
though a lot of people hate that and I
like to like run into a lot of like
political issues but they also run into
a lot of things that the characters in
Star Trek themselves the planets they
come from are often putting them in a
difficult place of being members of the
Federation like there's like a little
bit more complicated storylines but if
they're gonna do you know the new Star
Trek films did a really good job of kind
of reinventing these races to have yeah
no no there was something always just
like a little weird to me about the way
they depicted on all the shows until the
I mean Riker hitting on every one of
them and I mean if humans went to space
they'd try to have sex with everything I
mean for science for science
you know who I think would be doped see
like have their own spin-off series
y'all remember Deep Space 9 like the the
symbiote character I want to say Curzon
Dax okay character that has a what's
this there's sort of like a slug in
there baby slug and it basically is like
a symbiotic yeah yeah the slug I want
the slug back because I mean it sort of
was then I think it definitely could be
now like an allegory for like gender
transition because in in the beginning
of Deep Space nine Curzon Dax was
introduced
to a character that Dax had known from
like a previous host and it was an older
man yeah it was an older man and now
Curzon Dax is a young woman and each
time the symbiote passes on to another
host like the first part of the name is
the name of the host that they
originally had and Dax is Dax the slug
and the old Klingon guy was like oh like
I don't remember what the first their
original name was but it was like Oh
bozo Dax my old friend and Curzon Dax is
like actually Curzon Dax and the Klingon
guys me like Curzon Dax my old friend
and it was just like so cool to see a
Klingon be so accepting of our trans
friends beautiful so in this series then
every season does that does it change
bodies then a new actor completely no I
think that throughout Deep Space 9 it
was just Curzon dad but but for yours oh
yeah oh that would be kind of cool
wouldn't it like if we could see like
jumping through generations with Dax and
like meeting new hosts and like adapting
to their lives and problems like that
that sounds pretty cool to me I mean you
and I love lost and a lot of people like
to [ __ ] on it now but like man there's
some good like spin-offs great a bold
characters Richard Alpert is one that
jumps out to me that's a guy who never
ages he's on the island forever and ever
and ever
he's got the guardian of the island and
they gave him one bow Stern suits a
Nelson
violin he is in the Dark Knight movies
right he is awesome he was like my
favorite character on the show and they
gave him one episode where you see him
he's kind of like cursed to be the
caretaker of the island
and he has to like greet and all the
people who get like attracted and
stranded on the island and that's the
kind of guide to them to their spiritual
journey and ID so you kind of have a
perfect setup for different people to
have come and Dawn from the island and
he has to kind of explain to them the
weird physics of it and when you have
your hundred episodes right there Erik
Oh in every period show jumper out there
taste like a star I know this
yeah but her point is we have to go back
yeah by the way I returned to lost is
not a bad idea especially considering
like a lot of people still are like so
what happened
I mean like there's a lot more story
there's a lot of questions yeah would
you call it lost again yeah my pitch is
for Buffy the Vampire Slayer I know that
they're making a remake we'll see but
just go and especially since Jessica
Jones is going off the air or off the
internet stream I take faith faith the
Vampire Slayer
such a great character that you know has
has the great renamed Redemption arc but
is kind of like yeah my job is to kill
vampires and demons but also like I'm
not a good person either and I don't
know that was always charmed by Eliza
Eliza Dushku and just seeing her like
now I also love the idea of the aging
Slayers
because famously in the lore of Buffy
the Vampire Slayer Slayer never really
lives into their twenties normally so to
see one that's like like I got a kid and
like you know they're they're keeping
the kids in the car whatever well yeah
something like just like an aging
Vampire Slayer to to see that it's a
little bit of that trope has existed for
male characters a number of times which
is kind of like the grizzled old vet who
comes back and he's still like a great
shot or a given story right exactly but
just like you know I feel like Eliza
Dushku could actually pull off a badass
version of that too and she fights like
vampire suburban moms too so it's like
santa clarita diet yeah she kills the
people in Santa Clarita that day and I
like that it's just like a suburban mom
like yeah just a mom vampire show I love
it mom anything i watch is my point so
guys we're wrapping things up but we
always do with a rapid-fire round of
rogue questions these are questions that
were written for us but we have not seen
these so we'll see how they turn out
after homecoming and far from home damn
it Lucy I'm home with home would you
pitch for the next fighter
[Applause]
aside from home what else we got home
wrecked home alone home alone homeward
bound they're all dogs home right yeah
yeah I'm fine it was a stupid Lucy one
wins on that all right a Burbank
baskin-robbins so Burbank is a very
fancy area of LA I'm just kidding never
in it right now
Burbank baskin-robbins has been turned
into a scoop Soho a pop-up shop
HMS scotch they have a demo gorgon
Sunday roast what should be in a
demagogue on Sunday things like maybe
upside-down cake pieces of barb just
reminding you this is just actually an
actual baskin-robbins down the street
you know different take edible flowers
oh that's nice
hey are those things that are coming
like orchids or whatever are those
edible flowers and I saw someone go you
know these are edible right I didn't see
them again but I am wondering now every
time I see them like weird anecdote
build-a-bear is starting a record label
build-a-bear is starting a record label
what is your teddy bear themed band name
for instance bear Jovi the blink-182 the
Barenaked bears bear grizzly Roth yeah
yeah the bear born toxic event okay okay
we're getting a video of a family
fistfight in Disneyland went viral this
week the aristocrats what would make you
punch your mom while you're in toontown
how would what would make you turn on
your family about a visit to Disneyland
um if someone took away my Dole Whip let
me get a giant pickle
god damn it mom I don't get it you don't
like giant pickles reference oh you guys
really doing a scene about Dole Whip and
pickles there's two different things I
dip my pickles from my soul to get a
picture with like one of the probably
like costume people or the real that's
all it would take for you to put your
mom oh yeah just get out of my photo
winner the Ninja Turtle comics added a
female ninja turtle named Jenica but
shouldn't she have an artist name which
I argue like your artist girl's name
Jenica that right you know on
skateboards or whatever but I'll say in
Chicago yeah Jenna Kahuna koi anyways so
what uh what would be a better female
ninja turtle name yeah she's always just
sort of doing innuendo Lucy who's the
other person that Georgia brings along
sassy southern friend
it's her splinter
all right Disney has had to recall plush
toy versions of forky from Toy Story 4
due to a choking hazard
Erik why you keep trying to eat porky to
dislodge all the other fork it's the
shape of something that's supposed to go
in your mouth yes woody which Toy Story
character it says would you prefer to
choke on
which is a weird question mr. potato
potatoes maybe like slinky because then
you can you know this metal blade you
have like this thick ass potato I'm a
size Queen I want I'll say woody is an
obvious guys that's it for this show the
show ends thank you so much for watching
thank you guys so much for being here of
course we got our own Eric boss Eric
what are we covering this week on the
channel strange things breakdown you can
watch it right now and we have some
other spider-man theories that are
coming out Khanna Khan is coming up soon
oh yeah it's gonna be a lot because we
got Marvel coming back to Holly Age and
it's gonna be a lot for me to do I would
love some help so hopefully we can get
some people to help me out with that but
yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be a crazy
crazy couple weeks folks all right so
you won't be sleeping anytime soon and
that's great but what are you guys going
on well right now I'm on MTV's are you
the one it is if you see it right now
are you oh yeah yeah it's it's every
Wednesday at 9:00 8:00 central it's the
world's first sexually fluid reality
dating show the show itself yeah the
show itself and besides that check me
out on Instagram and Twitter at Danny
Park as da n NY PRI Kaz great I'm sure
it's spelled right here right now sorry
here so I'm Angelica Tran you can find
me on most social platforms at a yyt ra
e that's a tray I'm on Twitch and I too
am going to Comic Con but I'm gonna be
Scarlet Witch oh I think it's really
pretty good I'm excited for it so enjoy
yourself I'm not gonna be going I could
stay in an office and just watch
trailers as they come out I don't like
crap
yeah we're kind of like themed there
yeah love it alright guys I've been
Polina finally outfit Molina thank you
guys so much for watching yay this is
the part where we get to talk about
stuff that they don't get to hear
[Music]